تتخبط يمينا ويسارا في مواجهه معضله نقص
الغذاء تمر السنوات والخطر قائم هذا العام
البحث عن مخرج للازمه بدا بتصفيق حاد
لمسؤوليها في اجتماع قاده حزب العمال
الحاكم
اما زعيمها فيبقيه انهماكه في تطوير
ترسانته النوويه بعيدا عن افواه تتدور
جوان
اجتماع جاء قبل موعده المقرر في كل عام
لبحث ازمه الزراعه وقبل التطرق لتفاقمها
كانت الاولويه للتحدث عن انجازات العام
المنصرم لثوره ريفيه لم تتحقق بعد
جرسوا الانذار بازمه زراعيه وغذائيه يستمع
له كيم جونغ اون منذ فتره فلم يمر سوى
شهرين فقط على جلسه سابقه للهدف ذاته
وفي بلد يحتاج لمصارحه مع مزارعه بسبل
الخروج من الازمه اعلنت وكاله الانباء
الكوريه الشماليه ان المسؤولين وافقوا
بالاجماع على بنود جدول الاعمال وامر
بتغيير جذري لقطاع الزراعه دون الافصاح عن
المزيد
اما الجاره الجنوبيه لبيونج فقد درت نسبه
عجز في الحبوب في كوريا الشماليه بنحو
مليون طن اي ما يقرب من 20% من حاجتها
السنويه ووفقا لخبراء فان نقص الغذاء
الحالي هو الاسوا منذ تولي كيم جونغ اون
السلطه في عام 2011
وزاره التوحيد في كوريا الجنوبيه افادت
ايضا بالابلاغ عن وفيات بسبب الجوع في بلد
يخضع العقوبات المتعدده بسبب برامج
الاسلحه الى جانب مواجهه مخاوف من تكرار
كوارث طبيعيه قد تؤدي الى مجاعات كسابقتها
في تسعينيات القرن الماضي علي السمان
العربيه